okay we're running out of time what do
you guys like better
classic Bishop hat fold or crown fold
now the crown is more showy but the
bishop hat has a certain dignity I'll
kill myself if it's not the crown fold
oh okay thanks sometimes you have to
pretend to care about napkins to stop
hearing I'm out and I'm down wait guys
how to get my act sharpened why do you
have an axe also nice X thank you for
the turkey so I can chop its head off
when it gets here chop its head off
I ordered a live turkey it's being
delivered you know what they say the
yummiest turkey is the one that just
died in your hands Charles do you can't
kill an animal in here that's horrible
it's disgusting we won't let you do it
right Amy it's getting late don't make a
mess relax it's not the first turkey
I've killed in the friends bathtub it
isn't well your turkeys here alright
let's do this
pretty cool huh I feel like dester I
think I never actually saw the show the
overt gave me nightmares Charles are you
crazy no I don't want to watch a living
animal died and then consumed its flesh
how is this different than eating a
turkey that's been killed in a factory
because I don't have to see that it's
called living a denial you [ __ ] Gina I
know it seems cruel but it's a swift
death one painless chop removes the head
sound so bad and that's the capitated
corpse only flopped around for like a
half an hour you know what you won't be
able to go through with this if I give
this little guy a name he's now
Nikolai's that's my son's name go ahead
cut nikolaj's throat sorry Gina but we
need a turkey and you're the only one
complaining I don't like it either it's
not a fair fight give the bird a gun and
see what happens Sarge this must bother
you - yeah but eating a big drumstick on
Thanksgiving makes Terry feel like a
king sorry but it's five against two
wait you assuming Hitchcock and I want
to eat that Turkey
yeah thank you Charles do what you need
to do copy that
ha No hold up Rosa get the bird on it
I'll stand here and sacrifice my life
Charles's Bloodless I'm not gonna kill
you Gina huh then you already lost no
where are you going Hey you can run but
you can't hide the apartment will run
red with the blood of Nikolai's please
stop calling him that
come on guys it's getting late open the
door not until you promise to let this
little Turkey live out the rest of his
life with Rosa what I can't live with
you I'm an ideas man alright that's it
you left me no choice
go Thanks now give us the bird Godley
well not that bird don't take another
step
this ends now I am so sorry go great
party but be free noble bird be free fly
away fly to freedom Gina turkeys can't
fly this is looking at me like that
nobody make any sudden moves and those
talons are super sharp huh happy free
containers
[Applause]
all right
someone's got to go out there and kill
that feathery bastard Rosa you're always
looking for an excuse to behead
something don't look at me
Terry waste all that time building
muscles make him do it oh come on
you all know these are just for show
Gina's the one who set him free how was
I supposed to another big consequences
for my actions
enough I started this I'm gonna end it
is turkey time
[Music]
Charles it's been quiet for a while
everything okay I was gonna drop the
head out of this bastard but then he
looked me in the eye and I realized that
nature it's beautiful
he scratched you up real badly yep you
got me good okay
once I started giving him Gouda you
showed me mercy so we're not eating the
turkey then obviously not hello everyone
guess who just solved a twenty-year-old
unsolvable case wait what you guys
figured out who pulled the first essex
bank job yeah we realized we never
checked the daughters alibi she wasn't
at the softball trip she had access to
the plans and then she just confessed
that's right we arrested a woman today
because we are feminists so does this
mean you like each other now
yep do we still owe Oh doesn't matter
only matters what Amy thinks and
apparently she loves you thank you
that's the first time we've ever guessed
[Applause]
I just won 70 grand
so Rosa pack your bags we're going to
Tampa tight can't wait guys I'm a Duda
you